game was a monumental
uh shift of the superhero universe
um the scope of that movie the idea
of that film is something larger than
i think anyone imagine how's it going
everyone it's warren welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and
mcu and yesterday was the official
global press conference for the falcon
and the winter soldier and i was lucky
enough to attend it and a lot of you
have been asking me to do a breakdown of
everything that was said which is what
this video is going to be but
unfortunately they have asked us not to
show any footage or play any audio
with the exception of what i showed in
the beginning but we do have a
transcript of what everybody said during
the press conference and we could talk
about that and we need to because there
was a lot revealed about the falcon and
the winter soldier what it's meaning
is how impactful it's going to be
towards the future of the marvel
cinematic universe and if there are any
surprises that could be coming up
in the falcon and the winter soldier
series some of the questions that were
asked that we'll get into were
are there any surprises throughout the
show is there going to be more than one
season of the falcon and the winter
soldier
will hydra and or shield show up and
will the falcon and the winter soldier
affect
other shows coming up and the mcu by
doing anything crazy like introducing
mutants and i'll go over every single
one of these questions and answers
the entire press conference was about 45
minutes long the host kelly carter asked
a few questions in the beginning
and then it was opened up to questions
from the press which is where i got to
personally talk to kevin feige anthony
mackie and sebastian stan and ask them
my question
so we'll go over everything that
everybody said in this press conference
and talk about what it means for the
falcon and the winter soldier and the
future of the mcu
if you love marvel news be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel videos
so the press conference started off by
talking about the difference between
making a show
and making a movie like they're used to
making kevin feige started it off by
saying this is the second show that is
coming out to disney plus but it was our
first one that we started
he said that the writer malcolm spellman
got to experience a bunch of filmmakers
who had never done tv before
everybody was trying to figure out but
it was really meant to prove
to everybody to them and the audience
that just because it's on tv
doesn't mean that it's not going to be
as big as a movie so for those of you
who may be kind of worried that this is
a tv show and can't go as
big as a movie well the budget for the
show was insanely high
and having seen the first episode it's
insanely cinematic
if you were watching the beginning of
the falcon in the winter soldier and
nobody told you that it was a tv show
you definitely would think that it was a
movie
and marvel and disney specifically made
it this way director kari skoglyn chimes
in
and she said i approached it like a film
from the beginning we were making
a six hour film and just figuring out
where to snip it at certain hour marks
so it was shot like a six
hour movie then shortened just a little
bit because from what i've seen and what
i've heard each episode is going to be
between
45 minutes to an hour long head writer
malcolm spellman then talked about what
it was like to set the tone for the show
and he said that there was about a 12
second moment in captain america civil
war where it feels like every single
marvel fan knew that these two guys the
falcon and the winter soldier were gonna
be able to support a movie
or franchise and he talks about how it's
really funny and kind of a buddy comedy
like
rush hour but at the same time it's also
very gritty like 48 hours
so it's funny but it's going to have a
lot of serious tones and address a lot
of important issues
then anthony mackie and sebastian stan
stepped in and talked about each of
their characters personally what they're
going to be like in the falcon and the
winter soldier
anthony mackie said it's always a
surprise when the minds get together and
the information trickles down to you
when i first read the script i was
really happy and acknowledged the fact
that they were in louisiana specifically
because
that's the best state in the union and
new orleans is the best city in the
world
i had one request that if he was from
louisiana that i had to eat crawfish on
camera
i don't know who said no but somebody
said no the idea of sam wilson
he's always evolved in the world of
marvel comics and now he's evolved in
the marvel cinematic universe
if you remember when sam first started
out he was a hustler and
as african-american culture evolved stan
lee evolved him into different
iterations of himself
and then he said that he's excited for
the world to see the new and improved
version of sam wilson then sebastian
stan chimed in and addressed the
importance of mental health which is a
big part for bucky
in this show he said i've spent 12 years
with the character
you grow and evolve with the character i
felt like we had established the
character a certain way
then we had to go into this and go
alright well what is he like
now part of that was us honing in on his
sense of humor so to speak
that came into the tone of the series
and his dynamic with sam wilson and my
own dynamic with anthony
and then marrying the two where really
finally kind of zooming in on his quest
for identity and in terms of just really
accepting his past and re-educating
himself about the world that he's
currently in
anthony mackie then said the idea of sam
wilson and the character of the
evolution of
what's now known as falcon to be able to
go back and dive into his backstory
and his family and his surroundings only
betters the character for the audience
then he made a particularly funny joke
about kevin feige being the one to kill
iron man
he said we're in a place now where we
want the audience to know and learn
these new characters
especially since kevin feige killed iron
man they all kind of stopped and laughed
a little bit and then anthony continued
and said we have to put ourselves in a
position where we have to introduce
these characters to the audience and
give them that
relationship that history they've built
over ten years we now have six years to
play catch-up but
it's post blip and the story really does
address that post blip
question and that is what is actual life
like
it was from here that the conference was
opened up to questions and things got
really really good
one of the first questions was can there
be more seasons of the show
a question that fans have really wanted
to know and kevin feige jumped in and
laughingly said
who's gonna answer that one but then he
said it's a funny question
and it's one that we obviously get asked
much more in television because people
expect it to be like what people know
before
we really did approach it like we do the
movies if we were able to do another one
they're certainly ideas the slight
difference of course like with one of
vision they really will go back and
forth between the disney plus series and
the movies
sometimes will be a season 2 sometimes
will be a feature
so it looks like right now there aren't
many plans to actually make a season 2
but rather put
falcon and the winter soldier into a
movie of some sort
and this is because they're making these
shows like their movies
another great question that was asked is
why is sam reluctant to take on the
captain america mantle
and anthony mackie said sam's whole
thing is he went on this journey
this avenger journey over six movies
with steve
because of his respect and admiration
for steve he says
when captain america shows up at your
door you answer
that being said it's the pain the idea
of not being able to go on these
missions
not being able to help his friend
there's still people out there
that still appreciate camaraderie and
friendship just like everybody else you
don't want to see steve rogers go away
just like he was your cap steve rogers
was sam wilson's cap
that's why he says at the end of
avengers end game it feels like it's
someone else's
he's a fan just like everyone else sam
is just a regular guy who won the
lottery when black widow knocked on his
door
and he fell in love and was hoping to
have a spin-off with black widow
obviously he says that jokingly but who
wouldn't want to have a spin-off with
black widow and scarlett johansson but
that's a cool thing to hear that sam
looked up to captain america
as captain america and it's a big big
role to fill
another big question that was asked was
how is sam
and bucky's love hate bromance changed
since steve's retirement
sebastian stan answered this one saying
i don't think it has changed
it's only gone further divide they're
actually in similar places at the start
of the show because steve's no longer
there and they're dealing with the
consequences of that it's sort of thrown
them both into opposite corners in terms
of facing their lives their demons
their questions they've got different
things they're facing but they're in a
similar place in terms of questions
they're asking i believe
then of course a big question that was
asked are there more surprises
throughout the show
more surprises being more surprises than
we saw in the first episode and yes
there are some surprises
and anthony mackey said yes there are
many surprises we can't say who they all
are but there are many surprises then a
question was asked about
hydra and shield if they're going to
play roles on the falcon in the winter
soldier in the future of the mcu
and what's interesting is kevin feige of
course didn't give a direct answer
of course he's not going to say yes
hydra is going to be in the falcon and
the winter soldier
kevin feige doesn't reveal spoilers but
what he did say
is you can always look at the comics
there are new organizations like sword
that you see in wanda vision
and there's always an inherent need for
some organizations in the mcu
i think we're obviously going to see
sword in the future of the mcu but could
hydra pop back
up and could it be in the falcon and the
winter soldier due to that relationship
with bucky he certainly does address
things in the past in the very first
episode specifically his past when he
was the winter soldier but there are
many more episodes for him to explore
that in
and then of course in speaking about all
of the crazy rumors that are already
starting for the show a question was
asked
will falcon and the winter soldier have
a significant impact on the mcu or is it
contained to just this show
in which kevin feige replied the
characters of bucky and sam are
essential to the mcu whatever they go
through
could and should have an impact on the
mcu it is hard to navigate every fan
theory that's going to pop
up not everything is going to be as
world shattering as someone like
mephisto
or reed richards popping up in one
division and breaking the entirety of
the mcu
but there can be character shifts that
have massive massive implications for
the future
again this is a perfect kevin feige
response not really given us too much to
avoid
any type of spoiler that could happen
from a response but given us enough to
be excited
a question was then asked about what
we'll see with u.s agents origin story
what is it going to be like
and does it tie to previous shows and
the answer was
the past is prologue the clues are
everywhere in what has led to this
moment
certainly that character and that name
sometimes it's just a name and sometimes
we do pull of course from their lineage
and biography in the comics
stay tuned over the course of the series
and then the last question of the
conference was
actually my question and the last
question
is coming from the cosmic wonder and
it's coming from warren thompson
hey how's it going my question is for
kevin anthony and sebastian
i asked what it was like for captain
america to not be in the mcu anymore to
not be in their lives and if they felt
the responsibility
to lead future heroes anthony mackie
addressed me first and he said in-game
was a monumental shift of the superhero
universe the scope of that movie
the idea of that film is something
larger than i think anyone imagined
our goal and we've talked about this
i'll speak for sebastian
was not to mess it up so we didn't want
to be the first crappy marvel project
our job was to take the torch and not
make a bad show
i'm very happy to say that steve rogers
will be proud that our show does not
suck
sebastian stan then came in and said
that question that you just asked is
very much built into the arc
of both of these characters where they
are at the top of the show you know
and actually answering that question and
exploring that question
is very much their journey throughout
the show who am i now
what do i have to contribute that guy
did this and this
so what is going to be my legacy if i
even want that
so there's all these pieces to it that
are kind of interesting rather than just
coming out of the gate and saying you
know
i have all the answers and that was
pretty much the end of the press
conference as i said i had the last
question and they wrapped it up right
after
but as you can see a ton of thought has
been put into this show
it's a very meaningful show and based
off of what we've heard it looks like we
can expect a lot of surprises coming up
and when i personally interviewed the
director i asked her if we can expect to
be surprised and she said
i hope so and i'll be posting that
interview as soon as i get it from
disney so don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any
videos in the meantime let me know what
you think about the press conference
questions and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you